this is matthew mccon's clip oh yeah
let's watch it
maddie giggles yeah what is it what's
the clip dude let this rip
the whole thing i can't [ __ ] wait for
this i was
crying bro okay
not that not that i want this see it
yeah oh
oh so okay this is him on
what he's doing some podcasts okay
and not to make it a podcast about a
podcast but
actor [ __ ] oh man this is just the most
actor thing ever
okay it's talking about the cnn
interstellar when he's crying
okay and the caption is the interstellar
crying scene was done
first take all right not just okay let's
let it rip
so that was a monday morning um
okay it's not a scene about knowing the
dialogue
it's not about saying the right word
it's about reacting which is the word
you just used i got to go into that and
just say
relax and get ready to receive now
here's the trick and i did this with the
final summation and the time to kill
i walk in and
i'm pretty much in my on those i'm in my
own zone i'm not looking anywhere else
in the eye i'm in my
own zone to receive whatever is going to
happen
i love to receive to receive to receive
man just let it rip
let it rip and i hear and i have
something in my hand written in case i
need it
and then i hear no let's try to go okay
we're going to set up cameras over here
it's wide and here's wide and then we'll
rehearse it one time we'll play the
video
and i just kind of walked over without
looking at him kind of bumping he goes
yeah and i hand him this thing
it's a piece of paper that has two
letters on it c
u which means close up
so he goes that's me letting him know no
don't do the wide shots and all this
getting close now and there's our
rehearse and i just look up and i go
which is what i mean by going uh we
rehearsing live
all right i'm sorry who directed this
nolan
sounds like mcconaughey directed yeah
yeah
nope nope shut up nolan
we're doing it my way i love the the
hand roll so what is it what this means
is i'm rolling
we're going to do it live [ __ ] it do it
live
it's as if as if this could mean
anything else
i do this yeah i do this which means in
the movie biz
that means let's roll swirl
hey no hey i'm doing this i do this to
him
right
i'm doing this to him so i'm doing this
to him
which in the biz means roll
he says go wide i say uh uh
uh uh i want it tight this means tight
shot right here
tight shot that's what that means
he says so he so he says we're getting
wide
i say i i go up to him right and i go in
his ear and i say this
[Music]
which which in the game means close up
i want to go close up
he says we're going wide i say nope i go
right up to his earlobe and i just
give a nice little it's a
quick little suck on the earlobe and he
knows nope
no rehearsal we're doing it live
close up
actually be [ __ ] hysterical if he
started [ __ ] with whoever this
podcast host is
because he's just making sure like movie
terms and he's
every single time he's got to explain it
like that you know that means
let's we're live let's roll if he was
just like just [ __ ] just
like up to him i do this right and i say
no no
which in the movie biz means craft
services needs to be
replenished right right right right
right host is just
right okay yeah okay all right right i
see that i see
so if i'm on set and i go they're going
to give it to me close up
yes exactly that's right means yeah
right
right okay cool dude let this rip
roll and what you see in that take
that's the
that's the first step
everything after take one is acting
take one is where you really are
reacting
and so i wanted to see that tape of the
footage
of my children in the movie for the
first time
not have any anticipation of what's
going to come next or what they're going
to say next or
i want to and and just receive it and
then
let happen what happens i'm not trying
to do anything
in that scene well after you do one take
and you know take two and take three
we're okay but we were like take
one that's it because what are you going
to do now
take three or any anything after take
one take two and on
you can't help but kind of know what's
coming
and then you start to anticipate a
little bit and get ahead of yourself go
oh this is when they're about to say
that thing which really got me last time
we were already out of the moment
so that's take one
cool
sweet man a word for sure nice
that's what kills me about the whole two
minutes 17 seconds the only word the
host got in right there was
the dude's like no i meant i was asking
you about your real kids how are they
doing yeah
oh
oh well [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay well
[Music]
it's not about how they're doing it's
about
why they're doing how they're doing and
it's about
whatever they're doing because whatever
they're doing
then i'm happy
how they're doing is irrelevant
we're always doing okay
but why that's the real question
it's no it's not about how they're doing
or what they're doing it's about what
they're not doing
and what you're not doing matthew are
you just gonna
criticize every question i ask you for
the entire interview
or are we gonna get somewhere
i'm just picturing him on this ringer
podcast
in person and there's like a bowl of
like you know halloween candy or
something like that and he's like
he's like can i have one of these and
the guy's like yeah take one he's like
take one
one take i'll tell you about a story
[Laughter]
yeah everything reminds me of the movie
three minutes later and that was the
first take and that's what made the
movie
and then he reaches in the bowl and goes
and he just deep throats of twix yeah
then he winks at him
what else she got for me
and then and then the guy goes like you
know then the guy goes you know the
irony right there matt is we weren't
rolling
so we're gonna have to do that again
he's like oh well now
well now it's acting
nice that's good i'm not i'm no longer
receiving you
i could be i was receiving you right
before we were we were rolling he said i
was
just like you guys he doesn't mean
yeah like no no no no no
for two minutes tell him i was receiving
minutes i was receiving you and you were
giving
you were just giving it to me mm-hmm all
it all started with was one little piece
of candy
isn't that hey people at home i don't
he's like oh yeah
he put the little candy bowl out he just
threw it at me and i said i'm ready for
this
oh he was delivering and i was receiving
two minutes that's right it was
beautiful beautiful
i can leave this show saying i received
kyle brandt for two whole
minutes
ah cut can we can we restart no no no no
don't be ashamed
not gonna be ashamed about tell you
something
between two men
tell you something about cuts all right
i don't do
cuts in my performances okay
they want to cut what how are you going
to stay
how are you going to stay in character
if you're cutting
so i just haven't rolled the whole time
even when the scene's over roll
just roll just thinking about how much
of a waste that would be
and keep rolling guys uploading like
hours and hours of [ __ ] just nothing
whatever the [ __ ] that is
now when i'm on set when i'm even when
i'm off when i'm in my trailer i just
tell them roll
roll cause you'll never know what you
might catch
scene is being built roll
editor is like this is the [ __ ] worst
job
oh [ __ ] man picturing him like boss
around christopher nolan it's so
funny we're doing wide we're not we're
doing close
okay we're doing close we're doing close
i guess all right
ready we're rehearsing no rehearsals
okay well jesus [ __ ] christ i'm
i'm mad we have to rehearse there's a
fight scene there's a fight scene matt
we have to rehearse the guys
need to practice nope no
cause then i'm acting they're like [ __ ]
we should've hired christian bale what
the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you [ __ ] with my lights
oh my god